oh man Salam alaikum peace be with you
how are you have Victoria have you that
is me you got all this time to hit the
back what about time for the Deen show
in the Dawa well let's go are you ready
let's go now bro we're gonna be right
back works Hamza door says here on the
Dean's show bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be with you thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the D show all over the news is hysteria
one of the greatest men to walk the
earth has been insulted and we be up in
a war - if Jesus Moses Abraham all these
mighty messengers who came to teach the
people out of love God sent them to us
and there's a certain group of people
insulting them and we want to know how
should we as those who have submitted to
the crater and that is creation how
should we respond the right way not the
wrong way so when we come back our next
guest honza's here on the D show we'll
be right back
this is the thesis betangel
please be with us Salam alaikum o
alaikum Salam hey how are you good a
hundred love you got a nice right cross
there you know did you get surprised it
jumped out from the bag invited you to
be on the D show you're working out
training how long you've been boxing for
a while oh wow yeah at least then maybe
five years now yeah so I mean look we're
not here about to talk about boxing or
jiu-jitsu
you heard me open the show I mentioned
that look we'd be in an uproar would be
upset man Jesus peace be upon him no
Muslim is a Muslim as he loves it
Revere's Jesus is one of the mightiest
messengers of God Moses Abraham they all
came with its laws submission to the
will of God the last and final mission
to Papa had peace be upon him he came
with that same message he was a brother
to Jesus's right yes and he called
people to worship the Creator not the
creation yes and to be of the but best
character that you can be yeah loving
mankind
yes and now how should we tell us you
obviously know what's going on
you got some jealous people some envious
people whatever they are you know sick
heart sick minds and they made this
horrific movie what do you guys say well
there's a lot to say first and foremost
we have to react in a positive way okay
it doesn't mean keeping silent we
shouldn't keep saying cuz as Muslims
we're here to do what to call people to
this amazing beautiful message could
Islam Allah Azza WA JAL e says order or
ELISA video robic call people to the way
of Allah Azza WA JAL keeping silent is
calling no one to anything it doesn't
mean we're gonna burn embassies and kill
ambassadors this is haram and we know
this even the prophet sallallaahu I do
Salam upon him be peace he never killed
any ambassador even moose a demon the
fake prophet there was a respect so we
don't do things of that we don't kill
innocent human beings the prophets of
Allah what Adam said there is no harming
and no reciprocating of harm and he said
that if you want to be shown mercy then
you have to
mercy and compassion to others he said
and I shall rajala and his wife relates
that if you put compassion in something
and kindness elevates that you take away
compassion and kindness it degrades it
so we know these teachings but I mean to
cut you off before I left my thought you
said mercy compassion why do people see
that as the antithesis to Islam nowadays
it's usually when you say it's laundry
thing barbaric they think you know
swords flying you know you know
kamikazes suicide bombers what are their
two reasons the first reason is that
some of us we don't get up and we don't
warn we don't get up and we don't talk
to people about this beautiful message
although it's self-image psychology
defines who we are as an Ummah as a
Muslim community because the Prophet
sallallaahu iding who some said layup me
no I had the competitor you hit buddy
man you hit enough see you won't truly
believe you won't come closer to Allah
as I was out to the creator of
everything that exists unless you love
for others what you love for yourself
and what do we love the most
we love Allah will have Muhammad upon
whom be peace full of Islam so if you
want to be believers we have to give it
to other people so people just don't
know the other point is we have systemic
issues what does that mean it's a big
word systemic means there is a system
out there there's the media Fox News
Bill O'Reilly Pamela Geller I don't
believe she was to ban what's that food
what's that food but food falafel
falafel because she said is the food of
the of the Mujahideen I mean the this
woman's she needs help me Allah guide
all of us inshaallah mean so the point
is that we have all these people
filtering this information giving dower
their Dawa their call to the wider
society so it's input/output if you give
people rubbish to listen that's all they
gonna know so we have to one call people
to Islam and expose this kind of
systemic effect the effect of the system
and the way to do that to do that is
arise and warn and talk to people in a
really nice way because we should have
full for the trap brother Eddie that
this is about freedom of speech he has
nothing to do with freedom of speech do
you know why more is in every single
society freedom of speech is restricted
every society give us some
examples libel laws hate speech laws
product information we have perjury
contempt OCO there's a whole list in
European and in American culture in
legal theory there's so many so many
restrictions to speech so in a way this
like a smokescreen for open season on
Islam in a way that we all react a
negative way we're not victims the
prophet sallallaahu I he was almost
never a victim but we take this
opportunity to now expose the duplicity
havior why is it that a cartoonist in
France was sacked from his job because
he wrote a piece again against the son
of Sarkozy so for political
sensitivities there's no freedom of
speech when it comes to the best man
that books on this planet there's
freedom of speech in this particular
situation he what did he do he wrote
yeah he wrote against the son of Sarkozy
who was a politic Sarkozy was the
president of France
the president of France so for our
viewers who have no idea and then he got
canned he got fired
he got Catman okay well there's so many
more for example in Kate what about this
that's recent not just of Kent I believe
she's called Nell yeah okay what
happened with that bow they took a photo
of her uh-huh okay freedom of speech
expression European outlets wanted to
take that photo and publish it
everywhere France what happened they
apologized they said sorry they says
she's a human being she must be
respected what about prophet sallallahu
alayhi wa send them the best man I
walked on this planet so we have to
expose this as not a freedom of speech
issue because you know people think now
that we don't win debate and dialogue
Islam is all about the debate and
dialogue all about intellectual
discourse for instance even in eighth
century ninth century we had these
people could the Daria
now the diarrhea were the equivalent
atheists of Earth of the time he had the
tax abu hanifa and all these big
scholars and literally if it a me and
others discussing with these type of
people in a very nuanced articulate
manner but couched in human language now
even if you look up political philosophy
we have this man called John Stuart Mill
John Stuart Mill was the 19th century
British philosopher and he was the kind
of profit if you like of the liberal
tradition of freedom of speech and he no
he said it's very interesting and they
should learn from the
tradition he said that speech you must
speak for the competition of ideas so
you have truth accountability and
progress so this was the objectives of
freedom of speech by in this day and age
we don't have the real freedom of speech
of the rules speech or the objectives of
speech why because we think freedom to
degrade an insult is part of speech but
this is Haram in Islam and we have to
teach people these values I give an
example and you say you don't something
wrong right
yes and I want to count you I want to
put it in your place and if I start by
saying Eddie you smell man you're so
ugly you saw this you saw that your mama
this yeah what you're gonna say you
gonna be like what you're gonna hit me
right am I gonna account you properly No
so using vile and degrading language
goes against the very objectives of
speech think about it
using vile and degrading language goes
against the very object of speech so I
want to account you accountability which
is part of the objectives of speech but
using vile language and degradation goes
against that very objective I give
another example say I'm President Obama
okay I don't look like him but my smile
is as big say I'm President Obama and I
win the current elections and I start my
speech my address to the people by
swearing and rapping imagine you go
what's up yo yo baby
is he gonna fulfill the objectives of
his speech no do you see so freedom to
insult is actually goes against the very
objectives of speech in the first place
what about truth and science and
progress Stephen Hawking a very famous
British physicist he once explained
string theory some complex theory in
physics imagine he does that by using
pornographic imagery are you gonna
understand him you're never going to
understand him so this so-called freedom
to insult and freedom to degrade goes
against the very objectives of speech
how does it solve the problem well but
what about truth
what to also bill Huck we're all about
accountability commanded them are off
forbidden the monk are commanding the
good and forbidding the wrong were all
about progress
and all about the search for truth and
knowledge but couched in human language
with manners true civilization this is
where Allah Azza WA JAL in the Quran
says he doesn't like the utterance of
evil speech in the public domain so you
see how Islam we fulfill the objectives
of speech but we don't have this
ridiculous concept called freedom to
insult a Muslim mustn't insult anybody
we shouldn't harm anyone there is no
harming and a reciprocating of harm
according to the prophet sallallaahu I
knew something that included with your
tongue there are many a hadith prophetic
traditions attribute to the best man
that walked this planet that says be
careful your tongue be careful what you
say you'll be one of the first things is
gonna be thrown into the Hellfire be
conscious of Allah because of the
creation of creation and let's discuss
maybe after the break on how Islam
fulfills the objective of speech but yet
it's couched in human language to
connect with human beings in a profound
way not like this this means they've
lost the debate they don't want to have
intellectual discussion it supposed to
be exactly exactly
here what Hamza Tarsus does this I got
it we'll be right back here on the deed
show do you think these things are gonna
bring you happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain what we are offering in Islam
what we have found in Islam for
ourselves is a means by which our hearts
are in peace they're at rest they're not
discontent we are pleased with what we
have
and if we're gonna worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the villages I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender their self to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will that is it Islam was pure it was
just you just pray to God your Creator
back here on the D show and we're
discussing this movie that was made
insulting the last and final messenger
sent to mankind who came with the same
message of Jesus Moses Abraham calling
people to be the best that you can be by
worshipping the crater not his creation
doing good and we see some events that
are unfolding Muslims you know it's sad
to say you know burning flags and
embassies and all this so in the early
opening of the show definitely this is
opposite of Islam is that clear we don't
have a right a green light to go looting
and course not and isn't it interesting
just before I go on I mean when there
was looting in UK I heard the Muslims
were the ones who are stepping up and
they were guarding the business people
from you know the non not all of them
obviously botella you're from UK what
was going on with the summer riots the
England riots where there was huge rise
up another country and the police was
scattered everywhere so they couldn't
protect the community so the Muslims did
they they rose up and they commanded the
good and they did even did the community
the whole community doesn't matter if
you're Muslim now they were defending
all Muslims
well well that's the role of Islam
that's always here to defend humanity
origin s Allah says in the Quran which
means we have for the people we have to
protect people to maintain their affairs
to help them I heard this was in the
papers and this is everywhere it was
everywhere so this is what we should be
doing this is how we should be example
to America so this is a sadden you know
your heart you see this when they start
to you know bring the snapshots muslims
going crazy and you know what what
should be our response to that now we
know this obviously when we see these
movie this is horrific this has been
there since day one they're gonna be
insulted it's the truth trying to degra
gate the truth but now but we didn't
teach people who Mohammed was so a lot
we need to teach some people huh
Mohammed was a prophet yeah he was sent
with a message just like all the other
problems like Jesus and Abraham and
Moses upon whom be peace and what did
they say worship the one true God have
had pure moneth use would you be
offended now the not yet Muslim out
there he's like man hey you know if they
insulted Jesus or Moses let's say how
would you say if you offend any prophet
prophet this is blessed
in Islam this is against Islamic
tradition any prophet Moses that Korea
alias Jesus you love Jesus of course I
love Jesus loving the prophets is part
of our faith you don't know if Jesus you
can't be a Muslim
well I mean but do you believe he's God
what's not why not see what someone says
look he said I'm the way the truth and
light no one comes to the Father except
through me what do you have to say well
how can you love up if you don't worship
Him the Christian now our brothers in
humanity goes well first of all most
Jesus he taught us to worship the one
true God to worship the creation of the
creation he never saw how can someone
who's creation now saying worship me and
Jesus never claimed that anyway so you
can never of course you never call
people to worship Him never okay never
ever we don't find it anywhere
yeah and the point is what we have to
understand is this is that it fits the
whole plan of God if you look the Old
Testament the New Testament even the
Torah the Koran you see is all about
worshiping the divine no worshipping
your ego no worshipping human flesh no
worship praying animals no worshipping
society but worshiping the Creator this
is why it will pay you he was a 14th
century theologian you know he said well
if you want true freedom you want true
Liberty you want true freedom then don't
worship your desires don't worship
others worship Allah worship God the one
true God that frees you from the
shackles of your ego because we're we're
enslaved to our ego and our desires
we're enslaved to society what they want
from us but if you enslave yourself to
God it frees you from these things can
you be like someone who's not really
into talking about the prophets and that
and they're just got their mind warped
with MTV you got that in UK yeah and you
know nightclubs in that can they fit
into this area of obviously this is a
big thing like maybe show you what you
have what what phone do you have oh you
don't want to know a lie phone I got a
five dollar phone oh the iPad or the
BlackBerry famous phones okay you see
I'm not kidding
so the point is both let me just make
this point yet they don't know that the
reason they have the iPhone yeah the
laptop and the iPad is because of
Mohammed
any piece what mr. Mendoza you crazy no
I'm not crazy the reason we have the
iPhone in the laptop is because of
Muhammad upon whom be peace why let me
tell you the Scientific Revolution in
Europe the Renaissance in Europe that
allowed us to develop these things and
be a milestone for these things in
history only came about as a result of
Muslim Spain what was Muslim Spain
Muslim Spain was when the Quran the book
of the Muslims the hadith the traditions
of the Prophet Muhammad upon me peace
were implemented socially and
individually in Muslim Spain and the
historians could it that come viventia
which means the coexistence when Muslims
Jews and Christians could work together
in love and harmony to look into the
interconnect in principles of nature
which means to look into the science and
to look into progress and this is why
professor Thomas Arnold famous historian
famous academic
Arabist What did he say he said if it
wasn't for Muslim Spain we would not
have the Renaissance and we develop
things like that algorithm which wasn't
from the Islamic era the algorithm is
the thing that you require to have
things like the iPhone the iPad and the
PC now the reason is from Muhammad upon
whom be peace because he was the carrier
of the message of Islam which was the
Quran and the traditions this was
implemented in Spain Spain facilitated
all this tranquility to look into the
interconnected princes of principles of
nature that formed the Renaissance in
the scientific revolution would
subsequently in our era form the things
that we have is all from Muhammad upon
whom be peace another one you've been
too cool before
mm-hm you mean to God you when you're
going to call you suppose he presumed
what what are you pursued guilty or
innocent you presumed innocent right
before you give before guilty so
innocent before proven guilty or in most
cases anyway yeah so the point is you
walk into a court of law and you have
confidence that you're innocent before
proven guilty true yes
who is that from Muhammad upon whom be
peace they don't know is the last and
final message I am telling you bro let
me tell you why let me tell you why King
Dewey the ninth he was responsible for
forming this principle the presumption
of innocence in Europe he travelled to
the east he met a monk and this is
according to his chronicler yeah his
chronicler was writing all of this
history down he met this monk this
mockney the Bible this
knew the Koran and he knew some hadith
the prophetic traditions of the Prophet
Muhammad upon whom be peace and he
quotes a hadith the King Louie the night
if you want justice in Europe then
follow this civilization because they in
Samara he said that and he quoted a
hadith word-for-word if you don't
believe me go to now Haditha this is a
saying of the last saying of the last of
final compensation and Kingery the ninth
went back to Europe and he established
the presumption of innocence by the way
before this principle do you know what
people have to do to prove themself
innocent they'll fight to duel and if
you win you're innocent or you be burnt
at the stake or burned alive and if you
survive you're innocent so Muhammad upon
whom be peace gave a whole civilization
the presumption of innocence and we
could find this in the article by Marcel
boy sod in nineteen nineteen eighty it
was published in the journal of Middle
Eastern Eastern Studies and is called on
the purple influence of Islam on the
presumption of innocence we have even
more tolerance came from Muhammad upon
him be peace because John Locke who's
the post enlightenment thinker in
Britain he developed treaties on
tolerance and civil governance and he
even he even influenced the founding
fathers of this nation of America and
John Locke was influenced by Edward Polk
of the first Orientalist that travelled
to the east and he learned from Islam
and he was taught Islamic Studies at
Oxford University and John Locke says
I'm only influenced I am only influenced
by Edward Pocock and John Locke wrote on
civil governance you know where he
writes in that book where he says
governance is a vice jaren see translate
that in Arabic Khilafah the Islamic
principle the words are lies uses in the
Koran so Islam influenced Edward Pocock
Edwin Pokot influenced John Locke John
Locke influenced the whole of Europe
comes a tolerance and the founding
fathers of America and disco these were
three things by their progress and
science presumption of innocence and
treatise on tolerance and governance all
from Muhammad upon whom be peace they
don't know who this man is and now he's
and now he's who he is because the
Creator chose him to be the last
got links back to the crater of course
as you know why because you think any
man could develop these three core
principles that develop every single
civilization you think is a joke
an aberration of history some kind of
chance no this is a divine plan and we
see that's why the Quran says Muhammad
upon me peace is all Rama and mercy to
mankind so every time you use the iPhone
every time you use your PC
every time you look into science at
school every time you walk into a court
of law every time you see different
people and different nations in this
society because of tolerance think Allah
even if you don't believe in him you
know why because he's in Douma have made
upon me peace to give us these things
amazing amazing so many these are facts
not fiction
I gave you all the references myself
Assad the professor Thomas Arnold and
jaywalker historian that talks about
John Locke it's always a fiction get to
know this man get to notice may be
better for you to get to know this man
the last to final message a problem a
peace be upon him was a messenger like
Jesus Moses Abraham it came to the same
message yes what was that message to
worship the creation of the creation
that's why we right back with more here
on the D show when outside everything
looks good you see the hundred thousand
dollar car you see a lot of diamonds you
see a lot of females and they think that
this is you know this is a life this is
this is like no paradise right here are
with this my hands up to go into
someone's heart and change the heartbeat
your job is to topi water truthers in
the alley on your ears while we're
sitting here while I'm sitting here
constantly paying for the disease and
I'm already on the straight I'm already
in flowers already planning to quit
rapping bro I got mine don't worry about
me when we about you I'm in a loss arm
you fitted a little crude decide to
record labels I sign to Allah I worship
in but this still should be a car bro
I'm a Muslim you don't know what you are
just clown on the road trying to be a
star screaming out real talking a little
boy's game you need to get serious start
using your brain gonna hear about your
life how you doing all your pain how you
door for fight coffee back in the rain I
don't know that before bro it stopped
beside new I don't you gotta use this
like I'm begging you
I am
you
back here on the D shell special guest
honza here in the D show all the way
from UK houses everything in UK UK's
good yeah alright we're moving forward
masha'allah tell us now why do you think
it is people have this animosity this
hatred in their heart you'll see when
you'll talk to some people about Islam
you try to be rational reasonable you
know kind compassionate and some people
will take to it they'll accept because
it's the fastest growing way of life in
the world it makes sense some people
they just get this and my said they get
this rage this this anger some more
you'll hear on you see on the on the
comments the curse words the foul
language that insulting movies why do
you think this is well if you think
about Eddie if you live in an
environment okay and everything in this
environment says Islam is bad its
terroristic it kills people
it's backward and they hear there's not
money in the media on the radio on the
news and the newspapers and also
sometimes they may see Muslims who may
not be the best either sometimes okay so
you have all of this environment what
are you gonna think yes we do human
beings have an ability to stereotype
human beings look at patterns that's why
even science is based on looking at
patterns so the point is we have to
break that pattern now and say wait wait
wait there's some issues here you got
the wrong side of the story this is why
the things I told you now about Mohammed
happened to be peace John Doe next door
doesn't know about this he doesn't know
how Mohammed upon you peace affected his
life in such a profound way
the iphone/ipad science technology
tolerance justice presumption of
innocence all these things from this man
they don't even know they don't even
know so this is what we have to tell
them it's our responsibility to go out
there to KO people to Allah Azza WA JAL
to call people to the Creator to worship
the Creator not the creation and this is
our responsibility we shouldn't be
pointing the thing anymore Eddie
we shouldn't be victims the Prophet
Muhammad upon your peace was never evict
him you never said I oh look at these
people that people look what they're
saying about me the man's bringing me
down exactly he's not saying I say wait
a minute I mean I'm here with a message
even even in the Battle of the trench
what happened
when we were defending Muslims and
non-muslims of Medina defending
everybody not just Muslims and the
Sahaba but the Companions of the Prophet
they thought we're gonna be taking over
wiped out clean the Prophet Muhammad
upon me peace what do you do when he had
to remove the boulder and he striked it
so he could break and there was sparks
and what do you say he went Allah Akbar
god is great god is great God is greater
pleasure is yours the world is yours and
they're thinking look at this guy this
guy's almost gonna be annihilated but
yet his vision is to spread this
beautiful harmonious tradition religion
to the rest of humanity that man was a
leader that man was there a fair
creation he feared the Creator whoever
fears the Creator where was conscious of
Allah conscious of God he's not
conscious of anything else and that was
the reality of this man he had such a
vision for Humanity and that's how we
should be we should have this vision too
that we're going to cool people to this
amazing tradition don't worship the
creation worship the Creator there's a
few more questions in short how can we
and how do you like to when you're
talking to the you for target to the
adults and it seems like all they have
on their mind is Lady Gaga googoo and 50
cents and you know all this is wrapped
in their mind they're consumed with
movies music and we're talking about now
oh religion something that's kind of odd
for a lot of people but you know a look
we've been there done that and it's
beautiful you get excited talking about
the creator and paradise the rewards
that you get for worshiping him and at
the end of this life what do you what do
you like to tell them you know to get
them from out of that non reality to
this reality what do you what do you do
to get them out of the desert is very
hard I think the most important thing to
do especially when it's connecting with
other human beings as basically to
empathize with them you have to
empathize because sometimes Eddy you
know when we're giving Dawa which means
calling people to Islam quoting people
to the wish of the creator of the
creation when we do this we already
judged someone and so for example say
you were an atheist yeah and I knew that
but my view of an atheist was his
cold-hearted his scientific his arrogant
he's egotistical
all these judgment one
is and I think if I think you're an
atheist what am I giving dowa to I'm
giving doubt to the judgment not to the
person so as Muslims we should be like
the Prophet Muhammad upon whom be peace
and come with a blank canvas and not
really judge them even if we know there
may be a disbeliever or they may be an
atheist don't use your judgments because
you're going to be giving doubt to the
judgment not to the reality so first and
foremost we have to empathize and
understand the position why I in this
state why do people drink and take drugs
and go to parties all the time and go to
clubs why is because this is good self
annihilationism which in a simple way
means they don't like who they are they
don't know who they are the big
questions who are you why are you whose
are you for whom are you they haven't
answered these questions so we have to
fulfill that gap and tell them about
these things and term that the thing
that they're doing is also religious
that's what is it it's still religion
for them doing this repetitive acts
continuously with a drinking alcohol
playing games whatever the case may be
is like a religion is part of their way
of life that's all we say life we have a
way of life - and how do you know your
way of life is correct well I don't know
I just wanna have fun
well you know what I think I got
evidence for my way of life what do you
mean evidence what do you want to hear
this do you understand the concept of
Islam yeah sure I then talk to them
talking about Allah his reality God his
reality
talk about the Quran this book that
shook the world this book that made the
world this book that would save the
world we gotta go we gotta cut out just
real quickly some people just so they
know you're not an Arab no I'm not look
you're actually from Greece Greece yeah
the ganas
yeah how'd I see all right all right so
you you actually Islam is reaching the
Greeks the Italians the Polish I mean
let you know that he knows everybody
from all over the world so just to make
this a Bosnian Bosnians
it came to Greece it's there's a lot of
Muslims in Greece there's about a
million Muslims in Greece Greece a lot
of them are migrants by indigenous
Greeks about 300,000 amazing so tell us
now in short for the Greek out there for
the
Mexican for the Italian whoever's out
there the American and they like what we
had to say and they're like you know
what they're getting a different
perspective now tell us and short you
know what is Islam calling human being
too and sure what is Islam all about
well Islam is fundamentally Islam is
fundamentally Brothers's as our friends
that Allah God is calling you to
darussalam the house of peace he wants
peace for you he wants mercy for you and
the way to do that is by understanding
your purpose in life your purpose in
life is to worship the Creator nor
worship your desires himself no worship
social pressure the celebrity culture
but worship the thing that's much higher
and transcendent above and beyond and to
what and by worshipping God and seeking
his pleasure you get pleased so you have
double pleasure and then you end on the
day of judgment with good deeds on your
scale and you enter paradise because God
is inviting you to the house of peace in
the Quran the book of the Muslims Allah
God says God invites you to the house of
peace to bliss to tranquillity this life
is just a test and you passed his test
but being the best person you can
possibly be so believe in his oneness
he's not - he's not three he's not four
he's not five he's uniquely one put who
Allah who I had say God is uniquely one
and then you just worship Him simple as
that and how do you know how to worship
Him you follow what the Quran says
that's the word of God
and you follow what Muhammad says upon
every piece because we believe this to
be revelation - because he was the
carrier of the word of God so worship
God is that simple it liberates you from
the restrictions of this life and allows
you to see the expand expanse of the
hereafter and it's as simple as that and
you don't have to be an Asian or desi or
any other thing you don't have to change
your DNA to be a Muslim then one of the
first muscles was black one of the first
muscle was a woman there are Muslim some
all across the countries by Malcolm X
when he travelled he went to Hajj the
pilgrimage he saw all peoples together
in the same white clothes equal in front
of God that's what the Sun is to
liberate you from your ego and your
desires to liberate you from social
pressure we got so many pressures by
enslaving yourself worshiping God loving
God
and it frees you from that and you enter
paradise god bless you thank you very
much my god oh maybe the Creator rewards
you for being one any time we look
forward to having you back here I come
from alaikum Salam peace be with you and
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the DJ and you got to hear it
here we don't like when people insult
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind or Jesus or Moses or Abraham
they were the best of mankind they were
calling people to worship the Creator
not the creation but there's a way that
we go about there's a way that we go
about explaining things to the people
and it's not through flipping cars
burning flies killing people no it's by
educating them and calling to them to
the truth with wisdom and fair preaching
the best way because we're following the
best of mankind a problem of peace be
upon him so get out there invite the
people to the truth live the truth
invite the people to the truth and we
invite you to it pick up the verbatim
Word of God give us a call 1 800 662
Islam and we'll see you next time here
on the D show until then peace be unto
you